hey guys so we decided to come to the
park to watch some softball and all hell
has broken loose they're all trying to
fight with each other constantly why is
this happening I just wanted to come and
drink some gin drink avoid the rain and
watch some sports
quote from the crowd everybody sucks so
I didn't even do nothing another quote
heard here I don't I can't tell if it's
fighting between two teams fighting in
between one team and the other teams
just trying to calm everyone down
it'd just be crazy though everything is
calm or a moment I give it 30 seconds
before all [ __ ] hits the fan that's a
girl just yelling everything's okay
let's watch
I don't think they're gonna keep playing
I don't know
let's finish this another quote heard
some people are hugging
real emotional staff
cops helicopters scared
making sure everything's okay
kind of stuff to get really upset about
softball in the park on a Sunday should
be your livelihood and you should get
really really upset and fight when
things don't go your way it's the only
way to solve softball in the park it's
your entire life